[Music]
greetings internet it is i
rich roll your friendly podcast host
back for another
edition of roll on alongside my
hype man my co-host adam skolnick
environmentalist
journalist at large author writer david
goggins can't hurt me
co-author all kinds of things good to
see you my friend
baby diaper changer that's right a lot
of that these days
diaper changing how are you doing i'm
good i'm good you know i've been hearing
from the
ritual fan base about my diaper choices
there has been some chatter there's been
some chatter about my my
piss-poor diaper choices i want to say
this thank you for the messages they're
always very kind
and uh i'll just almost wanted to to
address it straight off
the bat i live in an apartment in a uh
we have a laundry room that is communal
and at the moment i'm i'm not prepared
to put soiled
cloth diapers in the communal wash but i
hear you
i want to be i want to be that brazen or
at least
moving forward you would figure out a
workaround
oh right well no i think i think um
we we are going to look into a service
okay
is the launch all right we'll just leave
it there uh
uh for those that are new to this
special edition format of the podcast we
typically
canvas a couple news stories
things of interest we call it the big
story we have a teachable moment we do
some show and tell
and after a break we listen we
we do some listener questions uh if
you'd like your question
addressed and answered you can leave it
on our facebook group
or preferably leave us a voicemail at
424-235-4626
and we thank you what have you been up
to lately uh
well last week um i was working on a
story for outside magazine
about uh kind of about this moment this
political moment and
adventure athletes and how they're
handling it so it's kind of like how the
nba players and nfl players major league
baseball players were dealing with
uh black lives matter and and and voter
suppression and police brutality
in a very public way uh which was kind
of uh
and for some athletes it was a new new
setting new forum for them
others had been doing it uh but
adventure athletes have been kind of
also doing that
in in their own way on social media and
so this is about a group of adventure
athletes who were kind of brought
together
uh to work on uh
a vote a voter campaign get out the vote
campaign in the name of
public lands preservation and climate
change policy
and what's unique about it is in it's
not just
a hey these are problems it's a an
attempt to
take back patriotism from the right
because for a long time since vietnam
war and the protesters are burning the
flag
the left has kind of left the flag alone
even though some of the greatest
advancements in america have been the
civil rights movement
where you know martin luther king john
lewis many others
kind of used the constitution to
embarrass and destroy southern
segregationists and you know barack
obama obviously mines american history
and philosophy
uh to great effect and obviously to to
the presidency
but for the most part you know
especially now you don't see
the kind of hug in the flag right you
know that's just not happening yeah the
flag has sort of been co-opted by
the right as a symbol of
you know a political point of view as
opposed to this
thing that should be uniting us all
right and you and
you know we're just talking to blake
here who's uh operating the cameras and
and audio here and he was talking about
in simi valley
you know these convoys with big trump
flags and big american flags in the back
of the trucks kind of
rolling through town and that has
happened in kenosha wisconsin and in
portland oregon and it has caused
skirmishes and problems and those people
are linked to
far-right organizations including some
white supremacist organizations people
who
are doing that and so you know it is
dangerous in 2020 can you embrace the
flag so tommy caldwell
legendary climber you've seen him in
dawn wall
you've seen him in uh free solo um
he uh is was one of those athletes
wrestling with
is it all right to embrace the flag and
so i spoke with him i spoke with claire
gallagher
who won western states 100 last year um
i spoke with a number of athletes
conor ryan a lakota skier and talked
about these issues and
you know because really at the crux of
it is this tension that we all feel
especially people who get out in nature
run on trails swim in the ocean whatever
it may surf whatever your sport is
we're adventure athletes people who are
enthusiasts of adventure sports
uh we care about the lamb because we
love it you know like it fuels us in a
level beyond
athletics it fuels us in a soul way
so can we love our is it possible to
love our country
when we love the places that are our
country you know of course it is
right right right of course it is but
there's this bizarre perversion like if
i was to hang an american flag like out
in front of my house
people would make an assumption about
what my political perspective is
so that's what it starts with so on uh
september 8th
tommy uh posted on instagram and you can
see it
um and i'm not sure when our story will
drop but in that post he's like i just
bought a house
and it had a big american flag and i
took it down and i understand that
because i would also take it down
uh because of the assumption but also
because i'm just not that into the flags
you know like i'm not into the american
flag i'm just not that into the whole
ra ra ra you know we're gen x man coming
up is
gen x yeah it was lucky it was detached
[Laughter]
so there's also that but um but now what
i think is so interesting jeremy jones i
spoke with him he's the head of uh
protect our winters he's a famous
backcountry snowboarder
uh which is a punk rock guy in his own
right and he
is the one who started this organization
basically all about we have to protect
our winters if we want to protect our
sport
and and obviously to protect human life
on earth which we'll get into
in a little bit and preserve the natural
land and resources that provide the
backdrop the landscape for us to
you know enjoy those sports so he he did
some he and protect our winners did some
um market research and found out there's
50 million americans who
uh do adventure sports and and they're
all outside and and he calls it the
outdoor state
and so we put together these athletes as
an attempt to let's take back
let's we we're the people that love our
land let's
let's show people we love our country
and um
and so jimmy chin um happy birthday
jimmy it's his birthday today happy
birthday he narrates this great video
and so that was kind of the departure
point of the story but it was also kind
of inward looking of
of this tension of you know you know
what does it feel like
to love the land and in this moment
what's it feel like to try to
is it is it the right time to embrace
the flag does it work
that kind of stuff so i don't know i
hope the story works
um you know it's like one of those
things you do your very best you talk to
a lot of people and you hope it drops
and
and it lands right uh it never lands
exactly as you'd imagine but um you hope
it lands for outside though
yeah outside yeah that'll that that
that's going to come out
yeah yeah yeah you're like insecure are
they going to publish this
no i mean you know we were talking
earlier on the phone it's like
you know you get scarred as a as a
independent journalist coming up when
you have stories killed and stuff like
that and so
part of me until i've heard and i've
gotten my notes and i know the plan i
always keep
i always like yeah do you feel like
you're jinxing it by talking about it
now yeah
it's going to be fine it is a weird
thing though
a very interesting thing like i love
america i love our country
i love the freedom that i have and you
know the liberty that i
that i have to pursue the things that i
love i love
being out in nature and you know
exploring and
everything that's great about this
country and how do you
reconcile that with not being
nationalistic in a jingoistic kind of
way you know right they're two different
relationships but we have to find our
way back to some place of unity where we
can celebrate
our collective humanity and this place
that we all share as a home
yeah and i don't say that explicitly but
that's the point is
is it unity is is where we need to get
to
um it's hard in this climate uh
for a lot of reasons um and uh
because mostly people are getting
screamed at from the poles
not from the center we don't have a
uniter we have a divider
barack obama was very much an attempt at
a uniter unfortunately there were a lot
of people who just weren't going to
listen to him
um so so this is an attempt for
environmentalists kind of this new
era this new wave of environmentalists
who are trying to take back the flag
and say listen if you love this country
like you say you do
you better love the land because that's
what the country is so
it's like that aspect and then of course
from an indigenous perspective
it's indigenous people's day today i
spoke to a couple
native athletes and they had some really
interesting takes on things and
from their cultural perspective and i
really valued that too
what's also interesting is that
environmental preservation was
originally the purview of the republican
party
right well just like you know they were
the they were the um
abolitionists too you know lincoln was a
republican
so it else it all flipped uh
somewhere along the line somewhere along
the line i know i know
so it all flipped but um
you know in environmentalism is it
shouldn't be seen as a
party issue it really is it's one of
those issues like healthcare like gun
control
that the reason it's it's skewed the way
it is along party lines
tends to be around corporate
contributions to the political right and
that gets conflated with jobs
exactly mm-hmm but those are cool yeah
so we have that to look forward to
yeah coming to outside online
at some point yeah man exactly thanks
meanwhile i'm getting ready
it's a heavy week this week i've got
three podcast interviews and i did two
over the last couple days so
i'm kind of ramping up yeah my schedule
the shark man
uh michael muller just went up that's
great can't wait such a good one man
yeah you got to check it out
he was kind enough to provide some
footage
of him swimming with sharks some of that
footage i think is from his vr
experience and we were able to
edit and weave that into the youtube
version of the podcast so people should
definitely check that out and you can
get a taste of like where he's coming
from like he's such an
incredible character it's a super fun
one
incredible and you have his book right i
do you've never met him though have you
i haven't met him i i
you know tashan who does these great art
books and photography books
um you remember they had a pop-up store
like on beverly or something like that
for a while and i used to go whenever
they put up a new exhibit i'd go in
there
they had a great hockney exhibit once
and then i was in there for some exhibit
and then i looked in the back i'd missed
the shark one they might have done a
book with him but maybe not a big
exhibit i can't remember but i saw that
shark
book um in the back and i bought it you
know yeah yeah it's so good it's an
incredible
yeah um i got matthew mcconaughey coming
on the podcast tomorrow
via zoom all right all right all right
obviously i would have preferred to do
it in person but we're in a pandemic
and i'm going to take what i can get
when it comes to wooderson
so i'm looking forward to that i'm
trying to wrap my head around like what
it is that i want to
talk to him about and and ask him um you
know typically i have people on the
podcast who
you know clearly are not as well known
as someone like him right
and the trick is like how do you
approach an individual like that who's
so well known and try to get something
unique and interesting
out of them that um you know is not
googleable
right well it's interesting about him is
well you're going to talk to him about
his book right
yeah i mean that's the occasion for this
he's got this book green lights coming
out i got an early copy of it it's an
incredible book he's an
unbelievable writer it's so well
considered and thoughtful
and interesting and i mean he's a very
compelling figure
yeah i mean how often do you see an
a-list actor trying to give you life
advice in a way that's
not kind of talking down to right
yeah we talked about this on an earlier
edition of this podcast right the advent
of the actor become
like lifestyle guru well you got it you
got will smith kevin hart
right but with him it's different like
there's because of his kind of hang dog
laconic laid back vibe
it doesn't feel um calculated
in the way that it might with somebody
else who's making like a bold move into
social media like it's all
very natural and organic yeah i think
it's genuine and i think it began
when he started stepping out and doing
you know keynotes and and and college
graduation speeches and people cottoned
on to like
the wisdom you know right he was able to
he's part of like a zen
figure yeah exactly yeah exactly so
anyway i'm looking forward to it yes
it's amazing i mean you'll get into it
with him but the origins but i read a
little bit about
like it came kind of it's like
his journals were this well spring for
this book right it's right it's a very
organic process
he's been journaling for like 32 years
yeah and he decided
during the i think in the early phases
of the pandemic like now's the time to
do something with this and he went off
to the desert
for 52 days and huddled up somewhere
without electricity and just banged this
thing out
amazing so on what a typewriter
i don't know yeah i don't know how that
worked
um more will be revealed yes all right
there's
a there's a whole section you can talk
to him about yeah uh
what are we talking about today what's
the first thing we want to get into
well you we were you sent me this
morning this
glenn greenwald animal agriculture story
the intercept did about
new documents revealing how animal
agriculture
the industry is surveilling and
punishing its critics
right so glenn glenn greenwald did some
investigative journalism
came out with this article on the
intercept as well as a a video interview
it's called new documents reveal how the
animal agriculture industry surveils and
punishes critics
glenn greenwald is a polarizing figure i
i know that well
but one thing he's always been on top of
is holding
the animal agriculture industry
to account for some of its sins and
that's essentially what he's doing here
and
and basically what he did was he got all
these documents
by virtue of a freedom of information
request
and it revealed the extent to which this
industry
really is surveilling and also
retaliating against industry critics and
animal rights activists and in the
crosshairs of this particular
controversy
is this veterinarian in the bay area her
name is dr crystal heath
who basically practices shelter medicine
she's affiliated with the berkeley
humane society
and has been somewhat outspoken against
certain practices that the industry has
been
engaged in over the course of the
pandemic to
reduce um particularly
pig populations like they're doing this
horrible
thing where uh it's called what is it
called it's called
ventilation is shut down ventilation
down ventilation shut down where
essentially
they i mean for all intents and purposes
they kind of
turn the air conditioner off and they
let these animals die a slow painful
death
yeah shut the windows down in order to
depopulate you know uh the
you know in the in the face of like the
pandemic and declining demand
and as a result of that they're
monitoring her social media
they're engaged in these retaliatory
facebook campaigns to make her look like
a crazy person
and this is all very concerning but i
think
a glimpse or a window into the extent to
which
this industry is willing to go to
protect its market share
and marginalize anybody who speaks out
against it
it's sort of another layer of what we
see
with um you know the laws that that that
prevent
uh any kind of investigative journalism
to transpire what whatsoever the ag gag
laws
yeah i mean it's nothing new really i
mean uh that gag
laws have been around for a while um i
was harassed i did a story on kfos for
sierra magazine in east north carolina
which we've talked about and uh we were
kind of i was with water keeper and we
were um
kind of driving around the perimeter of
some of these cafo operations
and checking them out looking at the you
know the lagoons and their pig
operations and um all of a sudden we got
our you know harassed like the the
the farmers came out with two trucks and
started tailing us and
through the these narrow roads in north
carolina i mean it was
it was crazy it was like they were on
our on our tailgate
yeah and harassing because you know
water keeper
comes around and monitors their stuff
and uh and so this is nothing new you
know
to be fair um
animal rights activists have been
infiltrating farm operations for a long
time and taking these pictures and
publicizing this stuff this is not not
new
at some point ag gag laws came as a way
to discourage that and so they could
criminally prosecute people who did that
which
seems like a violation of free speech
and is a violation of free speech but
that has happened
but now on the other end you have uh
people like crystal heath who are being
harassed and she seems to be strong he
mentions she's
she's strong and she's got her career to
a place where it's not going to impact
her
but it could someone had put images of
the ventilation shut down and that's how
the foia request and they started
prosecuting those people
so on the one hand people are getting
prosecuted and the department of
agriculture is involved in that on the
other hand
um the these farmers and industry types
are able to like
unleash holy hell on people like dr
heath and it's fair play
so yeah i think the the distinguishing
factor here
is the weaponization of social media to
perpetrate
what are essentially like ad hominem
attacks on these individuals
yeah it's one thing to prosecute them
and we could talk about that it's
another thing to
do you know a character assassination
funded by
you know a lobbying group that is
shrouding those social media campaigns
behind
anonymous accounts etc to try to create
viral moments that make
people look bad for basically speaking
up against something that
is wrong and should be addressed right
you know you're like
you're tagged as an elitist because you
think
torturing pigs is wrong you know what i
mean
like yeah like that's basically what's
happening right like people like her
you know you're an elitist and you're
and worse i think
they were there was some misinformation
about her that
got into kind of fellow veterinarians
were shouting her down or something like
that
saying right well that's where the
confusion comes in because if these
attack campaigns
you know are cast in a certain light
even a well-meaning or
intelligent you know colleague isn't
going to understand the context of
what's actually
going on yeah which is a broader issue
addressed in the social dilemma about
how
how social media is used for nefarious
purposes
it's true i i would just uh i'm not to
criticize intercept
i think intercept does some really good
stories but they don't pretend to be
even-handed and i'm not suggesting you
should be even-handed but there's like
words like torture and things in
in the in his story which you wouldn't
really write
if you're writing it for say the new
york times um right but he's not
he makes no bones about his perspective
on this yeah yeah he's
he's that guy that likes to kind of be
the pot stir
which is fine but sometimes i have a
problem with
left left wing journalist doing that
because you have a winning argument
and when you add that extra spice you
overplay a hand
and it doesn't help you like listen
we're for us to solve some of these
bigger problems
sometimes less is more because you you
don't have to outrage and inflame
you can also just present a winning
argument and sometimes that's more
effective and when you when you say
things like torture you're implying
motive like these farmers love torturing
their animals they probably don't look
at it that way
yeah and so in that case and i'm not
making excuses for terrible practices
i'm against kfos and all that but
you know as soon as you start using
think words like that
you are othering this this or this whole
group of people
that you actually need to change this
problem to solve this problem
yeah that was something that i spoke to
leia garces about who
who runs mercy for animals like finding
a way
to communicate with the people that you
perceive as your adversary so that you
can work together for change
and there's there's a very bold and
strong argument for that and she's made
a lot of progress doing
just that but i think activism takes
many forms
yes and you need the leia garces but you
also need
the glenn greenwald it's like he's
sounding a certain alarm
and he's going to write it up in a way
that the new york times is not going to
but maybe the new york times picks up
the story and does their version of it
maybe so i think everybody has their
place
and i don't think anybody goes to the
intercept thinking that they're getting
an objective
perspective on anything they're getting
glenn greenwald's
perspective or his staff's perspective i
don't know man
i think i think you're you know that but
i think
when when this stuff is is distributed
along
uh twitter and facebook and it just is
it's flattened that landscape is
flattened and now it's all just
news stories and it could be like you
know you open yourself up to
um if you're sensationalistic you do
open yourself up to arguments of fake
news right you're also you're you're
paving the ground for the counter attack
that's right basically right
right um well everybody check that out
in the meantime
yeah for sure it's worth through you
know reading ventilation shutdown
they call it vsd uh to depopulate pigs
just
it sounds horrific i can't believe that
this is legal
and now this is the first that i've
heard of it well kfos all cafos have
kill boxes
so like they stuff and and on bad days
you can drive by like if there's a
a virus that comes through a kfo they'll
kill all the piglets
and then they'll be stuffed in these
kill boxes out front like it's a mailbox
so horrible it's horrible what what was
the reporting that you were doing on
kfos what was that about specifically
it was kind of a two-tiered it was about
um how
these kfos how this one part of north
carolina eastern north carolina
turned into the kefo hot spot where uh
china is outsourcing its pork production
through smithfield
which is the big slaughterhouse and how
these kfl operations don't really
benefit the farmer but not only that
they there's no sewage treatment and
they spray the
fields with the poop and they put it in
lagoons and then when it's
during rains those lagoons flood and
destroy rivers and and the
end basically the ocean and then um and
e
and even when they're when there's not
rain when they're just spraying these
fields
the people that live around there
largely black largely low income
get their houses sprayed with [ __ ] yeah
and they can't even go outside even on
hot summer days
yeah and so i would talk to people in
that in the
community yeah it becomes aerosolized
and yeah you're breathing it wherever
you go and these farms tend to be in
lower income
areas that's right where uh
you know there's a minor there's
minority populations and populations of
color that are economically deprived and
these people get
sick yep and so mostly
black residents that get sick and then
the people working in the
slaughterhouses are mostly
immigrants and migrant workers from
central america and then the
farmers the people that own the far the
cafo operations
tend to be white and kind of the people
that have been there for years running
these
farming operations but they switch
switch to cafo and the difference is
they don't own the pigs they're just
paid to raise them
for the three to six months it takes to
raise a pig
and if they lose a pig that counts
against them
and so they don't actually get the big
payout of of the slaughter of the pig
they get basically room and board
payments right and it becomes very tight
margins for them yeah we've talked about
this a lot on the podcast i mean they
essentially become
almost injected yeah servants that are
they're servicing debt yeah you know
most of them and they're not really in
control of their destiny and they're
suffering as well and the state laws
were basically hollowed out by a guy who
was like the king of pig you know he was
like the he became industry muscle man
and um and he passed these laws that
basically made it legal to not
um treat this raw sewage and there's a
lot more pigs than people in this area
so it's like
right you know the humans have their
tree their sewage treated but not the
pigs
yeah this was explored in the
documentary what the health
and also in the upcoming documentary
they're they're trying to kill us
so that john lewis is behind he's been
on the show
it's just you know if you think about it
like they're just they're literally
spraying refuse into the air and you're
breathing it and he has interviews with
people
and they're in their house and they're
like our whole house smells like all the
time yeah
you can't get it out and it's obviously
it's in their lungs
yep can't have cookouts can't have can't
go outside in hot summer days
you know you can't you can't yeah it's
it's horrible unless these are happening
this stuff's happening
you know every day yeah yeah and when
you're driving by on the road you're
none the wiser because it's all
underneath these you know hooded
essentially massive huts they look like
greenhouses yeah they're just
massive warehouses yeah big warehouses
and and
they the the food comes in one
slot and the poop goes out the other and
and these animals live very short
you know i think it's only like three
months or something for a big to get to
weight
yeah all right let's switch gears yes
because
it's kind of the same gear though it it
is it is this podcast is sort of
becoming a documentary
review podcast every two weeks we've got
to find a new documentary to talk about
but we haven't had any problems because
there's been so many
amazing ones lately and this week
it is david attenborough's new
documentary a life on our planet
which we both watched the other day it's
on netflix
what a brilliant beautiful
man this guy is amazing what a life that
he has lived at 94 years old
in many ways the original naturalist
who's been documenting
the earth's beauty and bounty and all
these hidden natural environments for
decades upon decades
and he creates this documentary that he
calls his witness statement which i
think is so powerful
and the idea is that here he is at 94
nearing the end of his life and it's
almost like
here's what i want you to know about
everything that i've learned about the
planet
from the beginning of my career to now
where we've gone awry and where we're
headed if we don't course correct
yeah it's uh it's interesting how like
our climate
uh consciousness or climate conscious
conscience has gone from like al gore to
greta
and david attenborough you know like
from the youngest to the oldest yeah
it's it's kind of cool in a way it's sad
in a way
uh i mean he you see him i didn't i
didn't realize the kind of the breadth
of his
career because my interactions with
david attenborough is like through blue
planet and
planet earth and all that and his you
know
silky tones tend to put me to sleep to
be quite honest with you they're that
good
and like how is he not has he been
knighted he has been knighted he has i
would
say that guy yeah but he's been at this
what since like the 50s
going to like kind of going to um
you know new guinea and papua and places
like that for
for yeah maybe the early 50s yeah i mean
one of the things that's so striking
about the documentary is he says he
begins his career
when air travel was brand new that's
right so he's one of the first people
who's able to travel
to these places and show people
what's actually going on in these hidden
pockets of the world that
were previously you know unexplored or
never before seen
by most people i mean he's hanging out
with gorillas like arm and arm with
gorillas
it's very jane goodall yeah ask you know
in that regard
and i love the parts where it you know
you see him as a young man doing
all of this stuff and it just it makes
your heart swell and
great photography gives the yeah the the
cinematography and the sweeping
landscapes and
everything that kind of unfurls as you
watch the documentary is very profound
and
moving but just the gravitas because of
the life that he
lived he has this grandfatherly like
energy
and he's able to now you know in the
place that he's at in his life
look down on all of this like literally
look down on the planet from 10 000 feet
this 10 000 foot view
of the problem the history behind it
with a sense of scale and
proportionality that
is rare and is informed only because of
everything that he's done
prior to that and it reminded me a
little bit of
you've all know hirari's books the way
that yuval is able to
put distance between himself and these
things that we're too close to
to provide what seems like common sense
perspective
but is ultimately articulated in a way
that that
allows it to land with the profundity
that it deserves
yeah well part of that is because he's
studying at a distance but you know
what's cool about this is that
attenborough
lived it right you know it's very
personal for him
because he's seen this and he's seen the
bounty of
of of biodiversity and and
wild biodiversity which we got into last
time but he kind of expresses that like
the big the big alarm he bell he's
ringing is
um that we have a big we're on the verge
of the sixth
extinction and biodiversity is is uh
is kind of slipping through our fingers
and if we don't make some big changes
part of it it's it's driven by climate
and it's also driven by
industrialization and the way that
and and more people on the planet and
the way that we're developing the planet
the way we use it and so uh and because
of that
you know there's systems collapse that
are happening in rainforests and in the
ocean
and i think the witness statement comes
from i've lived this amazing blessed
life which he says
but um but i realized that i didn't i
didn't
i didn't blow this whistle soon enough
like i didn't see this coming
and now you're on the verge of seeing of
seeing it happen
and it really is happening and uh
whether it's glacier
glacial melt coral bleaching um
you know like you know palm palm oil
plantations
palm plantations yeah the bleaching of
the coral was amazing to watch that
him explain that and on some level we're
kind of
acclimated to these you know alarmist
environmentalist documentaries at this
point
but i felt like this one went to an even
darker more
dire place at the bottom of the second
act
and i think um it was buffered only
because he's such a you know kind of
loving beautiful compassionate person
anybody else who who would have been
hosting a movie like that who took it to
such a place like that would have almost
cast themselves as uncredible or like
some kind of
crazy villain because i found myself
thinking
this is utterly hopeless and then he
kind of revives it and
is able to stick the landing in a more
hopeful
place but um i don't know that i've seen
another documentary maybe
al gore's it's been so long since i've
seen that but
i mean he doesn't mince words about how
how dire the situation is right well so
i think i i don't have the percentages
right in front of me i have one of them
but not the other but i think when he
was born in the 30s
um or i guess it would be in the late
20s when he's born um
no yeah because he's 94 now so like when
he's born
something like 65 percent of of uh the
wild is still intact
and now there's 35 percent the ticker
that goes down the graphic ticker so now
it's 35
so the un has launched that it was
supposed to launch this year a big
campaign to protect up biodiversity
called 30 by 30.
protect 30 of the land and 30 percent of
the ocean
as protected areas no no no no human
activity no extractive activity no oil
and gas no palm plantations no
uh commercial fishing all of that
because there's been studies done
protected areas and specifically marine
protected areas actually
uh preserve make make an area more
climate resilient
and so these are both an opportunity to
store more
draw down more carbon like you said i
think you're going to get into the
drawdown aspect of this but
um so it's an effort to do that it's
also an effort to protect biodiversity
because
biodiversity is what makes these things
resilient so you need to keep that
biodiversity
otherwise the system collapses so we
don't want to get to systems collapse
that's what he's basically saying so 30
by 30
if we can by 2030 create enough
political will
to protect more land protect more areas
of coastal areas
we have a chance to to you know stave
off the very worst of climate change
right and the solution that he
articulates
is really lifted right out of drawdown
paul hawkins book
he basically canvasses the big
things that we can do and that we're
working to do to solve this problem
and what i liked is he was very
plant-based diet favorable yeah much
more so than kiss the ground he's like
we need to we need to adopt a
plant-based diet basically is what he
said
for the most part he's basically he
wants wild biodiversity
not like tame or cultivated by diversity
right yeah right i mean reforesting
rewilding
these are of the utmost priority to
enhance the biodiversity of these dying
ecosystems all over the world right and
rewilding is happening that's what
adding wolves to yosemite was all about
that's what you know there's people
trying to
put bison back on the in the great
plains from
um canada to mexico there's jaguar uh
rewilding initiatives in south america
and in uh in mexico i mean this stuff is
happening
so that's that's the rewilding is kind
of
really starting to hit right now so
that's a good thing another thing that
he talks about
and this is also from drawdown is that
we need to
raise the ceiling on the
economic viability of impoverished
nations and communities because when
communities are
doing economically better they're less
likely to have as
many children right right so it's not
really population control it's just
a fact that when nations are prosperous
they just
they tend to not procreate as much right
because they want more leisure time or
they
or whatever it is and also and also
educating women and girls
is about that's the biggest thing
keeping things which is also out of
drawdown what i did not realize
until we talked earlier is that is that
in certain
pockets of the internet this has caused
controversy yes uh david attenborough
has been called an eco-fascist
with because i had a hard time trying to
understand that yeah i mean uh who is
that
what does that mean the accusation is
that his take on overpopulation is the
driver of climate change which is what
everything's reduced you know the
internet being reductionist
that's the with the argument they're
making is that david attenborough is
saying
it's it's overpopulation that's driving
climate change and driving systems
collapse in nature
um not industrialization or colonialism
which is you know
so by by saying it's overpopulation then
the burden
and the guilt goes to poor people and
developing nations that
uh that aren't consuming as many
resources of course
that's not at all what that's saying
total mischaracterization completely
and and that's that's what i was saying
with with
uh the intercept not to but the i've
seen this because i
i am progressive and i write and report
on these issues that are important to me
as often as i can
it's not the only thing i do but i try
to do it as often as i can
and every time i do a story like this i
see
activists or other journalists or
whoever it is making arguments
that that are overreaches and when you
overreach on an argument
you you you don't help you actually you
actually
cause an opening for people to doubt you
you know
and so to to mischaracterize david
attenborough and suggest and to try to
trash him
when he's like one of the more unifying
figures
you could ever come up with right like
like everyone loves david
right i mean he was never he he like
created an instagram page and in 48
hours he had a million people i
i'm sure it's way more than that now
everybody
loves this guy you ride that all the way
you know you know what i mean it's like
we need unifying so uh
and and i think that's a crackpot theory
i don't want to give it too much fuel
but it's out there and it just shows you
how
you can be offended by anything
including a fact that if you raise the
standard of living
and you and more people come out of
poverty they have less kids
it's a fact you can examine any country
that's ever uh had a
growing middle class and you'll find it
in america you'll find it in japan which
is what he used you'll find it
you'll find it in in anywhere you look
right yeah right i mean certainly you
know
if we're being intellectually honest
there's too many people on the planet
and overpopulation is an issue he never
said
that we need to mandate population
control no he's just saying
if people are more prosperous they're
not going to have as many kids if every
nuclear family has two kids we stabilize
the population
and and it's also the way that like you
know he goes after
capos he goes after the meat you know
like like you said plant-based is the
way to go it's it's a very
you know so it's it's not just too many
people but that is a problem but it's
also
how uh you know how how we're feeding
everybody how we're getting our energy
you know like i thought one solution the
fact that morocco is getting
40 of their energy i didn't realize that
that was they have the biggest solar
farm right right
yeah right why can't we do that well
part of the problem is
uh we actually subsidize oil and gas
companies and
and you know until obama we didn't do
that for uh
you know renewable energy companies and
we're starting to do that we you know
obama did do that took some heat because
he had a project that didn't do well in
his early
early part of his presidency but now uh
then there was this incentive from
states and local localities and
sometimes from the federal government to
to do that so we need to have the
incentives in the right place
but we also have to disincentivize
things like oil and gas you know we have
to be prepared to
pay a little bit more at the pump you
know europe pays a lot more for gas than
we do
typically and because we're subsidizing
uh
you know petrol we need a manhattan
project
around renewable energy it seems
preposterous to me
that with the technology that's
available to us that we haven't scaled
solar
solar scaling it's it's some i've been
expl
because i know people involved in the
solar industry i've my understanding is
it's a battery issue you can't store it
so it's also yeah
janky like we've tried to figure out how
to do it at our house
and have made multiple attempts with
multiple companies and have
continually run into issues and
roadblocks that have made it
not cost you know effective for us to do
it i think the thing is to
have you know there's a great project my
friend jason caudle kind of launched up
in lancaster
where they basically saw he's he's a
city manager up there
and and and they were managing the
energy
up there and the republican he's a
republican the mayor up there at the
time
uh i think he was rex tillerson
republican and they said what if we
turned
you know city properties into solar
farms and they started doing it
and they started selling energy and and
we're competing
with these uh big energy companies up
there i think it was southern california
edison
which didn't like that but pretty soon
people started buying their renewable
energy from the city
at a lower price and now they're
basically a renewable energy broker
and that's what they've become they
become their own utility and so like and
that's a really smart
solution a very local solution um
yeah more of that as opposed to just
putting solar panels on your house or
whatever and writing it kind of
you know when it's systemic you have a
bigger chance yeah
it can't be reliant upon the consumer
figuring this out you need you need
these solutions to be addressed at the
top so that the origin
of the energy is coming from a renewable
source all upstream you got to go
upstream as far as you can
yeah but you're going oh anyway i was
just going to wrap it up by saying
everybody should see
this documentary on netflix yeah two
things i want to flag
one is like they we talk about they talk
about commercial whaling
one thing i like to think of when when
we talk about can we fix it in the ocean
especially
you can really regenerate very quickly
with marine protected areas and with
laws and
whale numbers is a great example of what
can happen when you stop
doing a specific commercial activity you
know humpback populations
in many parts of the world have really
rebounded sperm whale populations the
same blue whales as well
we can we can fix it and the ocean is
really
powerful regenerative machine and when
you can
enact these marine protected areas um
they can really start to
um get that biodiversity back swirling
in the ocean
um and so that's very exciting and so uh
yeah
we really need some strident regulatory
protection there and we need
you know a global unified approach to it
because right now
fishing is by definition overfishing
well not necessarily but there's a lot
of overfished areas
um you know commercial fisheries i think
are are fish to their limit is the is
the number
um because i've done a story on this as
well we can link to if you want to about
overfishing was around poke and it was
around it was around tuna basically
um and i think the number was 35 percent
he quoted his
is fish to the maximum capacity um but
when it comes to tuna it's something
like 80
or something like that wow i mean even
hawaii imports tuna
in in um when when it's not in season
around the islands never used to be that
way yeah
um tuna and salmon are kind of the big
fin fish that are
that are uh either overfished or they're
farmed in ways that are harmful
but there are people fixing those
problems and there are is fair trade so
like i know we're
we're plant-based we don't want to get
into that but there is a way of doing
that but
looking at this documentary um
you know plant-based people are not
necessarily out of the woods because
like if you look at
butter alternatives a lot of palm oil
yeah palm oil is a huge problem
yeah and i think that that's you know
it's an important point to make that
just by
eating plant-based that's a huge step in
the right direction
yes but we also need to be more mindful
about
what particular plant foods we're eating
how they're being harvested
where they're coming from because if
we're doubling down on the palm oil
we're perpetuating
exacerbating a huge problem and not just
here you know like
in indonesia i spent a lot of time there
and way back in the day it was all
coconut oil it was you know
you could buy it locally and now it's
bemoli this palm oil that everyone is
eating and
obesity rates have gone up and uh you
know it's
because palm oil is being made cheap in
borneo and borneo is the case study that
he uses in this film
right and in order to to cultivate these
products
you have to basically shellac the
rainforest
and monocrop it and that's the core of
what attenborough is getting at which is
the lack of biodiversity when you do
that
you just lose the ability to support you
know thousands if not millions of
species
absolutely and the downstream impact of
that is catastrophic and leads us to
this
system collapse that he's speaking about
how about a little uh
shout out to these lions of conservation
and
and fire you know david attenborough
jane goodall and sylvia
earle goodall and earl are in their 80s
um it's like there's a longevity lesson
in like having this purpose
coupled with nature right like something
i think our friend dan buettner might
speak to probably it's true like how how
old is gene goodall now
she's in her 80s mid 80s i think yeah
yeah she has a documentary out uh no i
haven't seen that one very good
soon to be reviewed on the future we'd
have to watch that again
depending upon the netflix release
schedule i suppose
i know yes we watch a lot of television
folks
um yeah it is interesting i mean it's
striking how
vibrant and present and with it
attenborough is at 94.
yeah what do you mean when you see our
our two presidential candidates going
head to head it's true
he looks younger than those guys do i
know well yeah but you got
joe does look good in aviators come on
he does did you see jim carrey
impersonating sorry i did but he does
rock aviators i've never seen a guy
like ever since tom cruise corvette you
know the whole thing
yes right well with that i guess we can
pivot to
a little bit of election related news
we're we're about 20 days away right now
20 days out um 20 days out man
unbelievable
oh my god it's crazy right
i want it i want it to be over it's not
going to be over
even when it's over it's not going to be
over no this no
go on i don't want to even get into that
guy's name but the specific thing that i
think would be interesting to talk about
here is is the content moderation wars
that are going on right now as we
as we enter this you know very last
phase before
everybody casts their ballot
and it's relevant to the discourse that
we had about
the social dilemma and the weaponization
of social media
and we're seeing these platforms that we
all know now are extremely powerful
in you know shifting the tide of public
opinion
struggling with how to deal with
everything from
campaign ads to outright misinformation
twitter's sort of leading the cause yes
i think yeah new york times has
has an article that came out the other
day twitter turning off some features
maybe you can speak about that that a
little bit i feel like jack dorsey
of all of the uh you know kind of tech
billionaires
has been endeavoring to try to solve
what i think is really
an almost impossible problem to solve it
seemed like he was the most laissez
faire for a period of time and now he's
like
actually the most proactive and involved
in in trying to
help and and i think if i remember
correctly the warning late
it's basically they're talking about
warning labels basically before you
retweet something if it's not
from a vetted news source and it's and
it's it's
potentially kind of getting into the
misinformation
realm you'll get a warning label and
you'll have to click
twice before you retweet it right but
how do you calibrate that so that's
being calibrated if i wanted to
retweet that glenn greenwald article
right
that is very much you know of a certain
mind
would that be flagged as potentially
misinformation because he has a strong
point of view on that issue
or is that kosher like how do we
distinguish between
misinformation problematic and vetted
like it's an impossible rubric it's the
algorithm bro that'll save us
yeah right um let's just we've
completely divested
our critical thinking skills uh to the
social media algorithms who are going to
decide for
us what's misinformation and what is not
i think it's like
it's supposed to be a team effort like
the algorithm kind of flags what it
flags and then
human monitors go in and look but
obviously there's so much
information flooding these networks how
can they possibly have human monitors
look at it
content every single day it's impossible
it is impossible
so but i think twitter also banned
political ads a year ago
and i think facebook and google are
banning them starting on election day
which
seems late ridiculous
right unless you're ken bone you have
decided at this point who you're
who you're voting for i mean i'm not i'm
not i'm not that
big a calendar guy but it does seem late
to ban him after the election
i thought it was at least with facebook
i thought it was originally like 30 days
before the election or something like
that
october 20th they're going to start deep
platforming or some clamp down and like
flag misinformation campaign like
specific campaign advertising which is
so ridiculous because when you look at
the balance sheet of facebook the amount
of revenue that they're generating from
from paid campaign advertising is pretty
de minimis
in the grand scheme of things and it
would not have taken much for zuckerberg
to just say
we're out of this business we're not
going to take money for campaign ads
period it wouldn't really have affected
their bottom line
so it's baffling to me why they're
taking such a hard stand on this well i
think they don't want to be i think that
that they look at all content as
the same they don't and they don't want
to be arbiters of what's true con
you know what's true and what's not
what's what's fair game what is not
um but that ship has sailed and they've
already but but like you said
they're doing it they've they've they've
deleted all of these q and on
facebook groups they're trying to
address that which gets back into
you know the whack-a-mole issue that
we're going to get into a little bit
right well what you had flagged with
twitter it's the same thing it's like
maybe
zuckerberg realizes it's whack-a-mole
i'm being generous because i think they
failed in a big way you know like
obviously from 2016 with the whole
cambridge analytica where they were
really micro targeting with
fake news stories and misinformation
those are the ads by the way we're
thinking of ads of like
you know trump saying vote trump this is
paid for by no
and in facebook an ad can be a [ __ ]
story
targeted to you and you click on it
thinking that it's a story
like an article but really it's an ad
um so that's the kind of stuff they're
they're they're attempting basically
to not be a part of any sort of campaign
to
subvert the results of the election
that's why
they're banning it starting on on
election day google's the same way
but these campaigns have been going on
for years at this point they're already
saying
you know you know donald trump jr on
facebook wrote saying you know we need
armies of people monitoring these
elections like self-appointed election
members well and there was that thing
with charlie kirk also where he was
behind
like a bot farm that was of young people
who were
supposed to be you know behind you know
pushing out
all kinds of campaign related stuff
around trump
even even today their story broke that
like the state republican party
in california is putting [ __ ] ballot
collecting
uh places to collect to deposit your
ballot stuff is not sanctioned with the
election board
that's happening right now in california
i didn't know that
yeah so you think you're submitting your
ballot and it's like a fake
who knows they're trying to say hey if
you trust us to turn your ballot fine
put it here but yes they could very
easily
like look at the ballot and throw out
half of them or whatever that's straight
up election year
election fraud third world coup oh that
is type stuff that is
but you know in this article about
facebook in the new york times facebook
widens ban on political ads
as alarm rises over election there's
some interesting
phraseology in here i mean it says for
years facebook has been striving to
avoid another 2016 election fiasco like
has it
has it really i don't think it has no
yeah um
when it was used by russian operatives
to spread disinformation and to
destabilize the american electorate
zuckerberg has spent has since spent
billions of dollars to hire new
employees for the companies
quote unquote integrity and security
like they're spending more
now in this whatever this is um
than the money they're probably breaking
in from the campaign ads themselves so
it's two different things so it's
right the campaign ads and then it's
also all the other
kind of shenanigans that go on on social
media and it's not just campaign ads
they've taken down 150 000
q anon accounts or some crazy or posts
or something like that right they're
trying to get a handle on queueing on
but that ship has sailed
right well wire just came out with an
article also on this a facebook man
won't stop queuing on i mean kevin roose
was reporting on this and he was
he was seemingly striking a real a kind
of optimistic tone at least
as of like a week ago or so thinking
this was actually
progress because all those groups
disappeared and the level of like
chatter which he pays
attention to closely around the kind of
q and on type stuff had seemed to
diminish somewhat
so he's in favor of the facebook taking
him down yeah yeah yeah i mean he's he's
heralding it as a step in the right
direction
i don't know that it's ultimately going
to solve the wired story looks at
like the fact that these these people
just go underground
they just they figure out different
emojis and
hashtags and then they resurface they
come up with different hand signals
yeah yeah we'll see um but matt taube
has an interesting take on all this
that he wrote about uh on his his sub
stack that's kind of a counterpoint so
let's talk about that yeah so he's
saying what you're saying basically that
it's a
game of whack-a-mole uh matt taibi for
those who don't know is
uh a great journalist with rolling stone
or he used to be with rolling stone
i don't know if he still writes for them
but he's now got his own thing
through sub stack it's an email you can
sign up for you should start a sub stack
me yeah i'm not sure i have the tybee
following but maybe after
a few but it's it's a pretty cool
platform yeah and you're seeing all
these journalists now who are leaving
traditional media
basically starting their own little fife
dumps they are
so they tend to have big followings i
think i'd need to you know flex out
maybe buy some followers casey newton
just did it
uh he's like a tech reporter more and
more people are doing it this could be
your thing this could be my thing right
i thought yeah
coming on the ritual podcast was my this
is part of your thing this is how you're
building the tribe that's all gonna
migrate to your substance you didn't
hear that i was gonna buy followers
no who was i talking to the other day
who was saying they were oh i had
um i had this is a tangent but i had
ravi patel on the podcast
the other day i haven't obviously
haven't published that uh
conversation yet but he's got a tv show
on hbo max called the pursuit of
happiness
okay and he's he's super funny and
interesting
and he did that documentary meet the
patel's like back in 2000 i don't know
or whatever he's very charming was he
former daily show
no you're thinking of um uh
he's worked with that guy what's his
name i i'm thinking aziz but it's not
aziz
it's uh i'll think of it in a minute but
anyway um
it's a pretty cool you know sort of
travel
show in the vein of bourdain where he
goes to kind of answer these questions
and
it's super interesting but he's never
been a social media person and his
social media was always kind of private
but then
with the show coming out he was like i
should open these
accounts up and make them public facing
but it doesn't have a huge following
right he told me he was going to buy
followers and i was like that's a bad
idea man don't do that maybe i can go in
with him
so you guys can pull your resources by
the way i would never buy followers come
on i wouldn't do that i can't afford
that
all right but back to tai ebi here um
yes taibi
uh doesn't need to buy followers he's
got a lot of them and he he's
uh has done some really important
reporting is the best stuff i think he
got his biggest name was he
reported on the financial crisis in
2007-2008 linked it to goldman sachs and
really came after goldman
did he write a book about that yeah it's
great it's like some
like the man eating squid you know
whatever it's it's very
gonzo he's a gonzo kind of guy and he's
very much
pro first amendment so you can read this
stuff and he's
and he he doesn't fall into any
particular political
no he was a he was very much against the
russia mueller investigation he thinks
that's [ __ ]
but at the same time and he's very much
into uh free speech he thinks the whole
kind of white fragility he
wrote a scathing review of white
fragility so he's but he is progressive
and um and he's done a lot of
investigative
he did an eric garner book that is
supposed to be amazing
and the death of eric garner so he's
been on the right side a lot of this
stuff but he's you can't pin him down
and so he is talking about exactly what
you say the sheer scale of logistical
task involved with showing through
billions of pieces of content a day
makes any hope an even-handed moderation
of fantasy
and he's talking about like do we really
want private companies
engaged in trying to tell us what's
right and wrong what's true
and not true that's the whole point of
having free speech
it's the best way to manage this
[ __ ] it only works
in the clearest of cases but you know if
there was ever a slippery slope
this is it i mean how do you even begin
to approach managing this problem right
like it's
look if there's a clear case of just
sheer insanity
okay you could label this as
misinformation but almost
everything in between has shades of
nuance to it there might be aspects
to certain reporting that's true other
aspects that aren't
you just can't possibly police this on
an internet
where milli as we said earlier like
millions of hours of content
and thousands of journalistic pieces are
getting uploaded
uploaded every single day if you took it
in how do we regulate big tech
direction what if one solution is
if you're gonna allow someone to post
new york times on facebook then facebook
has to pay the new york times therefore
in the in the financial transition of
paying the new york times
they are incentivized to uplift the new
york times or
any sort of like actual media
company like that's the way that it
should be that's the way it should be
because if you have to
if if someone posts a blog post and it
doesn't cost anything for
facebook to to use that piece of content
then maybe that's just that's how you
know right you know one is a
professional media company and one is
not
and if you have to pay for that blog
post then fine but like
you know maybe what we need to do is
stop allowing google and facebook
and uh twitter to be these distribution
systems of real
stories where the publishers are paying
the platforms to amplify
their stories and their content so it's
actually backwards right now it's
backwards right right this is something
that
um scott galloway talks about a lot
scott galloway is a professor of
business
at nyu he does a podcast with kara
swisher called pivot
and he's got his own new podcast called
profg but he's
out way out ahead and you know on a lot
of these issues and has been
talking about this you know quite a bit
lately
yeah he's saying this is what taibi is
saying the current system is the worst
of all worlds it's invisible to the
public
clearly invites government
recommendations on speech allows a
gameable system of anonymous complaints
to influence content
and gives power to an unelected
unaccountable body of private media
regulators
and the problem isn't that those people
right now might be they might be on our
side
when we're talking about our side when
we're talking about like trump
misinformation and stuff that
benefits uh bad actors that's what i
mean by our side
right now the algorithm might be tuned
in to be looking at
you know calls for election month like
bad faith election monitoring
but like 20 years from now it might not
be
the right thing that they're after you
know what i mean so like
that's the problem when you start to
pick and choose censorship that's the
problem with it
yeah it's cr it creeps yeah i
you know i i don't purport to have a
solution to it other than to know that
this is a huge problem right now and
it's
it's not in service to our humanity
or our unity as a population or as a
country
these things have huge real world
ramifications on behavior
do you feel like we're living in a petri
dish right now yeah
we've been foisted you know foisted upon
us are these incredibly powerful
social media platforms and without any
experimentation or research
we're just consuming them and using them
in this grand experiment
that we're already realizing is really
not healthy for any of us
no and again you know back to the social
dilemma i mean this is the this is the
dilemma that these
tech creators are are you know
ruminating over right now this idea that
they set out to make the world better or
to solve problems
and have also you know created problems
they couldn't have foreseen
that's it you know it's like you know
the unintended consequences of good
intentions
that's the story of i think it's also
important to remember
that yeah there's some ridiculously low
percentage
of the population on twitter we tend to
think of twitter as a proxy for
kind of taking the pulse of where people
are at on certain issues
but i think it's something like two
percent of americans are on twitter but
facebook it's like a billion people are
on facebook or more
yeah facebook is like a big one but how
many people
are the outspoken you know loud voices
on issues and how many people are just
sharing
photos of their family no i think
i think what kevin roose's stuff is
showing us is that
the people that you think are just
sharing photos of their family
they're they're sharing q anon posts
and i'm not even kidding i'm not even
kidding like can we just talk about cute
on just for one more second there was a
good story
i'm always available to talk about
here's
germany is becoming the next q a on
hotbed
i don't know if you saw the story no and
um
basically that means that right-wing
germans
are having a fantasy right now that
donald trump will send the american
military i'm not [ __ ] with you
into germany and depose merkel
and thereby elevating their interests
the jury
the average right-wing germans interests
uh because you know merkel is bad for
germany
so that means people who like hitler
are rooting for the allies to take over
germany
2020 oh my god
so as a jew i can make a hitler joke so
this is like this is real
this was uh inferred from some queue
drop
some cryptic you gotta read it's a great
story there's been a lot the same
reporter who's been kind of uh reporting
on east german um extremism and just
german extremism who who broke the story
about
how uh police off special forces and
police departments have been infiltrated
by right-wing neo-nazi types in germany
that same reporter does this story and
i'm sorry i for
i i spaced on her name but i'll get you
for to for the show notes so we can
make sure that's in there right but um
but
uh it's great reporting and one of the
main
publication new york times and this one
one of the big outspoken pro-q
or he's he says he doesn't fully believe
in it but he's a right-wing all-right
guy
is uh german but adopted he's actually
turkish descent
adopted and he's a huge celebrity vegan
chef
oh i think you did send me something
about this yeah somebody did
i did i didn't i didn't read it yet yeah
so isn't that crazy that is really crazy
how do you square that with the america
first make america great
non-interventionist
you know ideology that's kind of the
premise of the administration the point
is they're
both they're doing nationalism wrong
don't they don't these nationalists know
what they're doing
i don't even know man it's so crazy i
can't even yeah it's it's mental
begin to wrap my head around it i know
it's like
it's we are living the point is how do
you wrap your head around it but just to
exist right because all this stuff
if you if you peek your head under the
curtain or behind you know under the
hood
and you see what's happening which you
have to do because
like it's it's it's so critical these
next three weeks you know especially
certainly in this country
you have to stay in touch with it and
know what's coming but at the same time
it's like how do you then
pull back and just get on with your own
business and your own life like
you know because it is crazy making
where is the boundary between
just minding your business living your
life trying to take care of your family
versus
speaking up or participating in what has
become
just a very confusing morass of
misinformation
and emotions run wild yeah it's very
disorienting and it's hard to it's hard
to find your ballast in all of that
it's very weird but i have to believe
that
most americans are level-headed rational
actors
the majority are but is it enough to get
a bit you know like
we you know most americans voted for
hillary clinton
um well we will soon find out in 20 days
from now and we'll be here to break it
down for you
you know land this on a teachable moment
it's just a please vote
and to make sure that you cast that
ballot and make sure that it gets into
the hands that it's supposed to get in
yes so that it's properly counted you
know early voting or go
and drop it drop it in in you know there
are election sites there are state
and government-run election sites that's
where you want to look don't look at a
republican or democratic party site
look at the actual election dot gov
sites that's that'll tell you where to
vote
right yeah all right let's take a quick
break and we'll be back with a little
show-and-tell and listener questions all
right
and we're back so let's talk about
social entrepreneurship okay with a
little light dusting of conscious
capitalism
oh i like my conscious capitalism
this is the show-and-tell segment uh
there's actually nothing to show
we're just gonna tell you didn't bring
in a roll of toilet paper i didn't i
didn't well let's do that one first
yeah so that was the plan i was going to
bring in this roll of toilet paper
by a company called who gives a crap
we've been using this brand for a while
and you have as well right yeah we use
it april brought it into my life
and uh it's a great brand like when
everyone was was
scouring the shelves for toilet paper we
had
a big box of it in a closet and we are
not even toilet paper hoarders but we
felt like it because you ordered it
online
yeah yeah we just had already gotten
delivered i think this company blew up
when nobody could find their toilet
paper at the beginning of the pandemic
because that's how we
started ordering it and we get these
massive boxes in the mail with like more
toilet paper than we could possibly ever
use i don't know he's a lot we got six
people on our house so we go through it
quickly
how many bidets do you have we have nova
days we have two bidets
do you two people three people now two
bidets did you install those or did the
apartment come with bidets
no no i it's one of those um tushy it's
called
shy yeah and i said this company is
sponsoring podcasts i've heard
are those spots for them yeah to get
your tushy now
it's like regeneron well if you don't
have a bidet then you need toilet paper
and if you need it anyway first of all
like this company has not sponsored the
podcast
although i'd be happy if they did
because i think it's really cool what
they're doing
basically it's a direct to consumer
toilet paper brand it ships right to
your house and they donate
50 of their profits to build toilets
yeah
and i think that's really cool and i
think that that is significant
it's not five percent it's not one
percent
it's fifty percent right a tom shu's
model but
but like 5x right or 10x or something
right well the tom shoes model i think
for every shoot pair of shoes you bought
they would donate
one pair of shoes right so that's but at
their cost
so it's a little bit different like this
this is even more significant much more
yeah
um but i think it brings up a broader
conversation about social
entrepreneurship in general and the
effectiveness of conscious capitalism
um you have some thoughts on this let me
preface it by just saying
that i think these are movements to be
celebrated like when i have a choice of
what
toilet paper i'm going to buy i can buy
the one i've always bought
at the store or i can buy one that's
donating 50
of its profits to do something good
right so
that's inherently a good thing right and
that's going to inform
my consumer choices but i think it's
also important for
the conscious consumer to be able to
discern the difference between something
that is real and in the case of who
gives a crap i think it is real
versus this growing trend of kind of
green washing
where all these brands feel like they
need to be
part of this conversation and this
movement so
they step into it but they do it in a
very kind of
tokenism kind of way yeah co-op
meaningful way
like like the investment banker who's uh
taking a knee in favor of black lives
matter but really
you know is it's more like under social
pressure
right because you kind of have to do
that now if you want to be
you know in the marketplace yeah i mean
i think my thoughts came in after this
thank you brand
thing that is coming up right like
they're another australian company that
uh
that you sent me right so my friend
steve barr forwarded me
this thing about this company thank you
which i thought was really interesting i
sent it to you
yeah it's also you know of this ilk um
i'm still not quite sure what it is that
they
that they do they're like they're like
they do like a more affordable aesop
kind of uh product like like beauty
products or hygiene
healthy kind of health and beauty
products like
lotions and things and they i think they
made 10 mil according to this
video i saw they made like they had a 10
million windfall
from hand sanitizer during the pandemic
and then uh but their whole thing is
thank you like you give us money we're
gonna give we're gonna pay it forward
and we're gonna fund
uh you know hunger projects uh in
developing nations and so if you watch
the video it's africa
southeast asia they're doing these you
know it's it's it there's a
it it wreaks a little bit of white
saviorism which is an issue but my
problem with the social entrepreneurship
stuff is
does it work right is it is conscious
capitalism
it does it work on its own um is it just
another sales pitch you know that's what
i wonder i always like
i always i'm always skeptical of anyone
who says they're going to change the
world
because i mean i don't mean to be an
athlete that's the only way
anybody does change the world no no if
you tell me you're changing the world
it's not the same thing as showing me
you change the world and the reason i
came to that conclusion is
i've done some stories where i went into
i mean i've i've tried to report on on
issues a lot
um and the biggest impact i've ever made
isn't
from some issue story like the kafo
story we talked about or an overfishing
story or you know story about
displaced people's camps in burma it's
like when i did an uh lonely planet book
in thailand and reported on this small
families
pad thai stand that nobody really knew
about except for the thai people in the
area
and put it in lonely planet and then
when i came back three years later
it's like a huge restaurant and they're
killing it and there's something about
like the most effective change
has to work you know it can't just be
we're doing this thing the reason who
gives a crap works
isn't because of the latrines at all
it's because they deliver the toilet
paper to you there's no plastic wrapped
around it
it works on so many levels one level is
well that just comes up first the
product has to be good and it has to
function and it can't be in plastic it's
got it's got to be better in a lot of
ways it's got to solve multiple problems
not just one
and so it has to work so i don't have a
problem with social entrepreneurship i
just don't think because you tell me
you're doing x y i believe you yeah but
i do think that
in this age that we find ourselves in
that if you're starting a company there
has to be
a social entrepreneurship aspect to it
in order to be competitive particularly
if you're trying to appeal to
anyone who's millennial or younger and i
think that's a good thing
it is good but then i just think you
know not all of it is going to be
effective but to the extent that
companies are thinking about this and at
least endeavoring in good faith
to try to make some kind of impact that
isn't that something that we should be
celebrating it is but google used to say
don't be evil was their motto
and look what happened i mean like you
know like like like
when you do that basically you're
absolving the government from putting
into
a social safety net that actually works
you're absolving you're
absolving the public institutions from
doing can we do both though
we live in a capitalist society so can
we not
um you know marshal the levers of
capitalism to do what capitalism does
best which is to move
consumer habits and markets in a
in into a position where they can make a
positive impact
i would love that but like you know uh
what's mrs jobs steve jobs uh
wife's oh i forget her first year yeah i
know what you mean she bought
the atlantic she bought you know she her
foundation
bought california sunday some other
really good niche publications
and just this week she fi you know they
had to fire people
because at some point you know the angel
business the angel you know wealthy
entrepreneur
or benefactor that kind of stuff doesn't
always work and so then what happens
when it when it doesn't work or people
lose interest
you prevent the government from
performing the function that it should
be
performing i mean a perfect example
would be ppe right like at the beginning
of the pandemic and we didn't have that
right it was the billionaires that came
in and had to like fill in that gap
which is good you know in wartime you to
marshall the to have the government come
in and say look we need this
and this from you i'm all for that like
i i'm not saying business doesn't play a
role and i'm not saying it's bad to
you know be keen on social
entrepreneurship i think it's great
um i just think that uh
you don't want to get to the point where
we're relying on businesses to do that
because
because it's the same problem with
relying on big tech to regulate itself
it's like you're you're asking private
companies to do these things when in
reality
there should be latrines where i know we
love who gives a crap but there should
be latrines in these places because
there are people there right but there's
but the thing is there aren't i know
right
so there is this argument either an ngo
is going to go in and solve that problem
or the government in that particular
locale is going to take care of it
and in the event that that's not
happening let's
buy a little who gives a crap i love who
gets i know believe me i've
so are you used to you earlier do you
are you a believer
in the idea of conscious capitalism at
all or do you find that to be
i am i i think what we need really i'm
i'm i'm kind of just going off the cuff
here i have not looked into it i'm sure
there
is some really good research into the
benefits of social entrepreneurship and
conscious capitalism i think there is
because
there there definitely is a lot of
academic studies on
does foreign aid work and it doesn't
always come back positive on foreign aid
and so this is kind of a neighbor to
foreign aid it's like
foreign aid adjacent it's not it's not
big foundations or foreign governments
bringing in boatloads of money but it is
a smaller scale version of that
and and what does that do to the places
that you're helping
long term and these are situations where
we're not going to be able to audit you
know where the money's going
how effectively it's being used i mean i
can tell you
i'm no expert on conscious capitalism
but i've got a little bit of experience
with it and i
was a speaker at john mackey's conscious
capitalism conference and
john mackey the ceo founder of whole
foods um
he wrote the book on this he's a big
believer in it he's got
some interesting you know political
ideas as well
but i was able to spend a weekend at
this conference and
meet a lot of these business owners ceos
etc
who are involved in this movement and i
left that experience feeling
better than when i arrived that people
are thinking about this and trying to
use use capitalist forces
to solve problems that are currently not
being addressed or are
under underserved or not adequately
being solved yeah
and i'm all for like this idea like i
think one of the biggest problems we
have is that
we have a market capitalistic structure
which
which incentivizes big companies that
own lots of smaller companies
to bleed every last dollar from of
profit out of a product so we're
spending
150 on shoes that cost 20 you know 20
to make and ship you know like like i
would like
a much kinder economy that makes it
easier to live
like i would love that um we don't have
that um and
and it's nice when social
entrepreneurship comes up it would be
great if every company
thought about you know what's better for
society like should we maximize our
profit here can we
afford to not to here i would love that
there's just no way to make it uniform
um but i am in favor of it yeah yeah
effective altruism is probably better
like if you're looking to be part of uh
solving a problem that's not being
solved right now yeah
uh effective altruism is basically the
study
of how to best use resources to solve
problems the most economically
um i had a guy in the podcast a while
back who's you know one of the
big movers in this in this world his
name is william mccaskill
and basically he's like he's part of
this
um community where they pledge a certain
amount of their income every year i
think
i think 30 of his annual income
something very significant
maybe even more like he's kept his his
salary
at some you know quite low some that
allows him to live and then everything
else he gives away
and the the manner in which he decides
where to donate
his money is dictated not by his
emotional attachment to certain causes
but
to what is most effective and and
that means that he ends up like buying a
lot of malaria nets like that's the
cheapest thing that you can do to solve
them well it's the same with like
yeah building it's not as sexy as like i
want to start a music school
in you know downtown la or something
like that where you have
like you feel emotionally invested in it
or you know some kind of connection to
it
that isn't necessarily logical in the
calculus of
money versus lives saved right so yeah
well
what was that there was that story years
ago about the guy who
runs his company and decided to cap his
pay at like 100 the ceo the captain's
paid a hundred thousand dollars
yeah yeah dan um i met that guy at a
conference
and it's great these are great stories
and like but i don't see them catching
fire i don't see
i don't see you know what i mean i don't
see it so like it's great in the small
scale we can only affect our locality i
love it
that's good and i'm in favor of it i
mean i i would like this all to work and
i think to save to solve our really
complex problems we need it
we need so many different solutions so
i'm in favor of these small solutions
i just don't think you can depend on a
hand sanitizer
salesman to solve them how dare you
all right one more thing i want to share
before we uh move on
from show and tell i guess this is a
show-and-tell uh
back to you know reviewing content on
netflix i suppose we are netflix
but here netflix uh i watched um
song exploder on netflix the other day
for people that don't know song exploder
is a podcast where
the host um basically takes a band or
song
and over the course of the podcast like
deconstructs how that song
was made with interviews from the
musicians it's super interesting if you
are curious about the creative process
in general like how do these things come
together and he does it in a very
engaging and fascinating way
that podcast was developed into a
limited
television series on netflix and
i think what's interesting about it and
significant is that
we're in this
we're in this moment right now where the
entertainment industry
is looking at podcasts as a means to
develop them for television shows
and a lot of show a lot of a lot of big
podcasts have been
translated into television shows but
it's primarily been
in the true crime kind of genre right
dirty john and shows like that that turn
into like episodic television
uh and some of these shows translate
well others don't
but i think song exploder is probably
the best example
of a podcast turned into a tv show it's
wonderfully beautifully
exquisitely executed with amazing
cinematography
and really compelling interviews so i
only watched two episodes i watched the
one with rem
and i'm biased because rem is my
favorite band but they deconstruct
the song losing my religion with
interviews with all the band members
i just thought it was brilliant really
cool and then lin-manuel miranda i
watched that episode
deconstructing the aaron burr song from
hamilton
yeah i watched those episodes too i
thought the coolest thing about that one
is the fact that
uh what george washington was meeting
with his cabinet
at in washington heights right in
washington which is i never knew that
lynn's neighbor right i just never knew
that i know and so that's it
brings it all home yeah and he used to
sit in that house and write
and wrap too i guess it was open it's
open as a museum and he would just sit
in a corner a chair and work all day and
people would come in and
wander around yeah
trying to channel you know the energy of
that era i didn't realize it took him
five years and like
you know he when he first uh was
speaking about
this project you know at the white house
he because into heights was out so he
had a little name and cachet and
obviously from the
the group that he was in right freestyle
freestyle supreme
um and but people were laughing at his
idea
at first yeah and uh and look at what it
became i thought that was a really good
episode i think rem i mean
i didn't realize uh to the extent i
guess looking back it makes perfect
sense how losing my
my religion took them from like this
kind of quirky alt band
to like u2 level superstar yeah it was
it was a huge you know uh
lever in that gear that you took them to
and and how that song became like an
anthem to different communities of
people for different reasons
out of athens georgia athens georgia at
that time remember they had rem b-52's
indigo girls
that athens georgia was a was a little
hotbed it's a great town
i love athens too yeah i do too i love
it
i did i did a talk there a couple years
ago i'd never been there before and i
just basically
uh just put the earbuds in and had rem
on the whole time
i was there i was like i wonder where he
grew where where's michael stein where's
that church
where's that where was their like
headquarters their little recording
studio
they lived in like a a reclaimed church
that had become like a heart
like peter peter buck and i should have
asked somebody where that is
i i would have liked to visit that but
what i like is it's really creative how
they use the tracks like they get the
demos they get right they get the
like they isolate out all the different
parts yeah and then they play them to
the band members and then you're able to
watch their facial expressions in real
time like listening to that
and something about the fact that rem
has happened so much longer ago and
they're just older dudes makes
like the gravitas hit me a little bit
more than having just watched hamilton
and lin's been getting so much play
lately although i did like that one too
but
like the rem just kind of looking back
at this
song you know and they have perspective
yeah you know because they're in a
different place in their lives yeah
um all right win of the week first stop
we gotta talk about sarah hall
this the i think win of the week with
respect to rafa nadal
who is amazing and that's my lakers
he's putting on his lakers face mask yes
big ups for the lakers last night and
lebron james and
fourth title and fourth finals mvp i
mean
amazing and if there was a great story
that lindsey kraus did for the times on
uh on the dow of rafa and like lebron is
kind of somebody i actually
i think when he speaks you can actually
take pieces and apply them that's what's
so great about sports is you could take
pieces of of of you know answers that
they might give you to questions
and use that as fodder for how you live
your own life like i remember when i was
writing
one breath um he had he was talking
about how you know you you leave it all
on the floor
and live with the results and i had
never written a book before
a narrative book like that before and
and i was like
felt like i was in over my head and i
knew the only thing i could do is give
it my very best and live with the
results
if it got rejected if it never made it
anywhere i would be able to live with
that
and and this week i think the theme is
sometimes you don't have to win to win
you don't have to be
first place to win the event like and
and we can talk about these
right two people just to put a pin on
lebron
what what is most you know amazing about
that guy is like here's a guy who from
the time he was a young teenager
was given the imprimiter of like being
the next
hugest thing ever like he was going to
inherit the reigns of michael jordan
and he [ __ ] lived up to it amazing
he exceeded expectations actually like
he it's hard to actually
be given that expectation and to exceed
it 99 times out of 100
that would have crushed that person
people fail yeah yeah
and he and to do it at his level and now
he's like turning
helping to turn stadiums into voting
areas and like
yeah his activity off the court is
equally impressive if not
maybe more impressive in terms of the
impact and the legacy that that guy's
leaving and and
and and it's so weird to be so good and
so dominant to accumulate haters like he
has and and
you know a lot of that i think came from
a racial place when he
decided to to take control of his own um
career and put people that he was close
to his friends as
as kind of you know his agent and the
person who was working on
movies with and those people are now
like ballers
and uh and he did it and they're all
huge successes and uh and you don't hear
any negative like there's just no
there's no scandal with lebron it's
amazing all right
but on to sarah hall but yeah so yes
winning the race without winning the
race
yeah i mean she's definitely the story
of the london marathon absolutely
she got second uh it's just such a
magnificent
performance on her part so in the midst
of this
stacked field in which she's competing
against the current marathon world
record holder and the 2019 marathon
world champion she runs her personal
best like 222
six fastest of all time for us women
but what was what really captured
everybody's
amazement was how she was just passing
people like crazy at the end with this
unbelievable kick
including in the last mile passing
uh ruth chip i don't know how you say
her last name
chep nagitch yeah chip negative who's 26
she was the 2019 world champion
uh owner of the fourth fastest marathon
time ever
and it was this redemptive moment
because sarah had to drop out of the
olympic trials
and you know she's in the later stages
of she's 37 right yeah it's like
she's 37 years old not only that she
adopted
her and ryan her her husband ryan hall
the
legendary marathoner adopted four girls
sisters from ethiopia
so she's like this mom to these four
girls i know she was a mama
running now too i think the older one of
them at least is like doing really well
in running
um it's just a beautiful story and to
have ryan you know her husband um
as her coach there's ryan shared some
footage of him like
like screaming at her like the last mile
she's running by he's like losing his
mind
it's really cool and on a fitness tip
have you seen
what ryan hall looks like these days no
so
you probably have an image of your mind
of him winning like the new york
marathon
typical marathoner build like super
skinny
yeah tall guy when he retired from
running
he just went into the gym like a beast
and now he's just gargantuan really it's
crazy yeah i mean
he put on it took him two years but he
is an absolute monster now it's his
unbelievable in two years he like
doesn't run
really at all i think he was gonna i
think i saw sarah sharing something
about how he was gonna run an ultra
marathon like a 50 miler on no training
i don't know whether he did that or not
i should look into that but anyway he's
just built
like a mack truck now it's it's kind of
amazing that is amazing i didn't know
but hats off to sarah what an incredible
performance to run that fast late in
your career while
juggling everything that you're doing in
the midst of a pandemic while being a
mom like all of that it's just such an
incredible story
really hats off and then my win of the
week
is uh david goggins how could it not be
how could it not be he finished second
at the moab 240 running what he thinks
is
the race of his life uh so far um and
this is a guy who's done very
well and and won some big ultra races
197 entrants in this
moab 240 and for the backstory on this
there's a couple things one is he did he
ran this race last year
and was in second place i think or in
the top three
and went off course there was like a
sign misplacement or something or some
sort of
like controversy there and he went off
course like by 10 miles or something
i think it was even more than that was
it more than that so he had to run back
and then um coming up to the biggest
peak on it he started having fluid in
his lungs like
having some altitude problems right it
was like a pulmonary edema
and they basically forced him to go like
well they didn't force him but like the
i think the doctors are like maybe you
got to get down to altitude and so he
left the race went to his hotel room and
started feeling better and then went
back out on the course
by himself and they didn't let him
finish at the finish line
but he finished like because right now
there's still only
five runners that have finished and you
can finish like tomorrow i think that's
it's some i forget exactly
and so there's most people are still not
not even in yet
and uh there's several dnfs already but
uh
so that was one backstory so he's coming
back this year but this year
at some point he's going to reveal how
[ __ ] up his knees were he's
kind of hinted at it he's shown some
therapy stuff he's shown himself on
in doctors offices he just this week
before the race
showed himself having his knee drained
where it said half a baseball's worth of
fluid was coming out of one of his knees
but when he finally reveals this story
in its fullest and
and how how [ __ ] up his knees are
that's what makes this to me one of the
most amazing uh athletic accomplishments
i've ever heard of
like like that and you will agree with
me when you finally when he finally
tells the story i agree with you now
because the guy he lost to and lost i
mean he finished 10 miles i think he
finished
a couple of hours behind this guy i
forget exactly
but let me tell you what this guy this
guy has like set the record for running
across the atacama desert he set the
record for
this uh michelle gralia the italian
set the record for running across the
gobi he wins all he's
won bad water he wins almost every ultra
race he
he enters and david was gaining on him
at the end
the guy had like a pretty good gap on
him though i mean like 10 it was 12
miles 10 mile
i checked maybe when they had like 40
miles to go on it i thought it was all
he had like 20 miles on him yeah but he
only finished like eight miles ahead wow
yeah like that's what i'm saying so he
was king so yeah that guy had
he had a a pretty solid lead that david
was gaining on and then
there was david and then there was a
huge gap yeah and then it was a cluster
so it was like basically those two guys
were way out ahead of everybody else
yep and then there was kind of a pack
behind those guys that were pretty
closely packed together
three guys together yeah but let's count
the ways that this guy is a savage
because like i don't know if we even
have time i mean it's
it's crazy because what happened to him
last year
was like the most epic story ever and i
remember when he rejoined the course and
he's running along
and he did a little instagram video i
was like you know quit if i sign up for
something i don't stop you know just
because the race is over doesn't mean
that i finish
and i finish what i started or you know
whatever was saying like he had so much
respect for the
slower runners that were still out there
suffering and he wanted to be out there
with him that's what his point was you
know like
they'd all finished by the time he went
back no there were still people out
there that's why he went back out there
i didn't know he's like there's some
people out there still grinding he was
in the hospital for how long just for
like a few hours
like overnight no no then he went to the
ho the hotel room
yeah all right yeah so this year when
did he have
knee surgery i don't think he had knee
surgery i just remember
a video maybe a couple of months ago
where his knee was like the size of a
water yeah never had any surgery
he dealt with therapy and he kind of did
did some stuff and he put some of that
on instagram
but i'm not gonna get into what what
i've seen in terms of like the medical
on him reporting on him you got the
inside but i'm not going to get into it
it's not me to say
but it's um but trust me when you hear
the whole story
uh even gralia will be like the guy
becomes
like what the [ __ ] is right what the
[ __ ]
the other thing that's so prototypically
goggins about it
is that any other athlete
who has like a profile on social media
would have been sharing the lead up to
this race like i'm getting ready to do
this race here's my strategy this is
what my training looks like
none of that not a peep nobody even knew
that he was doing this race at least
publicly facing
right so suddenly it was like oh goggins
is in moab
and he's in second place like wait what
like he didn't announce that he was
doing because he doesn't do that because
his thing is
that's for me yeah like i'll do these
little videos
once in a while because you know i have
to even though i hate social media and
i'll like
put you on blast with some crazy
inspirational message
but i it's not incumbent upon me to
share anything else i don't
like sharing and i do this racing and
this training for myself that's right
it's the same thing with his fire fire
training you know he doesn't put that on
his social media either he does that for
himself but then there's always a
message there's always something that he
can use
to inspire people out of it whether it's
through uh
a talk or an instagram post or uh you
know
the book um and another thing that was
prototypical goggins is when he crossed
the finish line
he banged out like i don't know how many
like 20 push-ups or more
and just pegged him out right right when
he crossed the finish line
like most people 200 is there video
good for you david yeah that's
impressive unbelievable
and uh the world you know the world
needs that story yeah so
sure thank you for that yeah and then
that's the kind of stuff like
you know that's why he's hit people
connect to him
and his legend it's like because he's
the proof that we can push through our
own smaller
problems yeah it's intense man i love it
all right let's do some listener
questions do it okay
hi rich hi adam my name is cameron i
live in the beautiful
oahu hawaii and i'm probably one of your
younger listeners
i'm 22 years old and i have become
immersed in the world of health and
wellness
i've come a long way on my betterment
journey but one habit i can't seem to
shake is
overdoing it with alcohol i've tried
cutting it out completely
but then i end up feeling isolated from
my peers
i've tried having a limit on how many
drinks i will have but often end up
disrespecting that boundary
and then feeling anxious and shameful
for it
i haven't given up alcohol completely
because i enjoy having one or two drinks
and i use drinking as a means to network
and socialize
do you think it's possible to set
healthy boundaries with alcohol and
stick to them
or do you think it's safer to just stop
drinking altogether
considering this relationship i have
with it
thinking of being a sober 22 year old is
quite daunting to me
and the more habits i change the further
i feel from relating to the people
around me
as someone i look to for health and
personal growth system
as well as being a recovered alcoholic i
would love to hear your advice on
possible ways i can resolve this
thanks guys thank you cameron how cool
would it be
to be 22 and living in oahu first of all
i want to be 48 living in a while i know
it sounds good and it sounds like you've
got
a cool life um and thank you for the
question
i mean the first thing i would say to
you is
to your to your specific question is it
possible to
set healthy boundaries around alcohol
and stick to them
only you can answer that question baked
into
what i just heard it sounds like you've
tried to do that
and have failed so i would
encourage you to kind of think about
that
alcoholism is a self-diagnosed disease
and i can't
say whether you're an alcoholic or not
only you can make that judgment call for
yourself
but to the extent that your alcohol use
is starting to interfere
with your well-being which it sounds
like it is i think it's
um worth uh
spending a little time looking into that
particularly as somebody who's immersed
and interested
in the world of health and wellness if
you're interested in those things
i'm not sure what role alcohol plays in
furthering whatever goals that you set
for yourself
in my opinion it's only going to be an
impediment
and i think these experiments like hey
let me go out and
cap my drinks maybe you know i'm gonna
go out and see if i can be with my
friends and only have two drinks or
maybe i'll only drink beer
or only go out on these nights these are
all
uh you know experiments that that i've
played around with myself only to find
out that they never work
um maybe they'll work for you i don't
know but it sounds like your
relationship with alcohol is making you
unhappy and it's moving you further away
from what it is that you
most aspire to so my suggestion
to you is to why not try to go
sober for 30 days it sounds like you've
done that in the past you've had stints
where
you've given it up completely
but that's impaired your ability to
network and socialize with your friends
so
what is that about why is it that you
feel like you can't go out and network
or socialize unless you're drinking
is it because it makes you uncomfortable
is it because it's no longer fun
and i think that's where the work is
invest in what it is
that is leading you to be uncomfortable
around that specific dynamic and i think
that will be
a means of of connecting with
what exactly alcohol is doing for you
and is not
doing for you you know on top of that
like how can you be in health and
wellness if you can't control your
drinking that's
that's like the hard truth here and i
think it's it you know this might come
across as daunting
and scary the idea of giving up alcohol
but
in truth you won't know unless you try
and i think if you just try to do it one
day at a time like they say
in in 12 step and not worry about
whether you're ever going to drink again
you might find yourself enjoying it in a
way
that you haven't previously
but i think you know when you give up
alcohol completely and then you find
yourself
isolating that's because alcohol is
that alcohol is the the grease that
allows you to interact socially and when
you remove that
you're lacking in the tools to be able
to do that sober
and the kind of um idea behind recovery
is developing your emotional aptitude
and your social skills so that you're
not reliant upon
a substance in order to kind of
gracefully you know
navigate your your friends and these
social situations so
again it's not for me to tell you what
you should or shouldn't do it's not for
me to diagnose you
but it sounds like if you're thinking
about this
that perhaps it's a problem because
people who have a healthy relationship
with alcohol
are not the people that that leave
voicemails like this
right so clearly there's something about
this that is unhealthy or dysfunctional
for you
and i can only speak for from my own
experience which is
when i stopped playing these games about
well maybe i'll have two drinks or maybe
i'll do it at this
you know these nights but not these
other nights when i just let go of all
of that
and accepted help and started to
you know um live sober that's when my
life
improved and got better in unimaginable
ways
and i just want everybody to have their
version of the experience that i had
so i would encourage you to explore
12-step in your area i don't know what
it's like in hawaii but i think if
you're in hawaii
they're kind of functioning normally
because they've kept the island pretty
protected from kovid so i suspect there
are probably alcoholics anonymous
meetings that are in person and perhaps
you can
go on the internet find out where those
are and attend
set aside your preconceived ideas about
what it might or might not be
and just show up with an open mind
listen try to find
somebody that you can talk to try to
look for the similarities rather than
differences and if you can find that
person to talk to
sit down with that person tell them the
truth of what you're really going
through and i think that will be
revealing in what you want to do going
forward
well said thanks cameron i miss anything
dk's here okay dk could have dropped a
better sober bomb then
no i think it was perfect yeah i think
it's normal for a 22 year old to feel
that
right yeah because you're probably used
to running with a bunch of people that
drink
right right because most 22 year olds
yeah exactly
but i i would say that uh you know be
careful
sometimes like uh it's it's
every the people who we're closest to
are mirrors right that's what the yogis
like to say
and so you might getting think you're
getting a reflection you might be
thinking you're getting some
like you want you need to connect with
this person and the only way to do that
is to be on their level but that might
just be a story you're telling yourself
you might be able to go out and hang out
and be completely welcome
and connected with people without
drinking well you can
yeah you can but with your group of
friends i mean it might not isolate you
from your friends like you think
yeah it might not be as isolating as you
think probably won't be
but you know you have to experiment with
that like 30 day experiment seems like a
good way to go
why not yeah all right
let's go to the next one this is a
related question
hi reg hi adam um my name is john i'm
from london england
i am seven years sober
i'm also five years planned based and
rich she's been
a real inspiration for me as somebody
who i guess is a taipei male it's
rare to find role models in sobriety and
in plant-based eating so
thank you so much um my question is
around sobriety
um rich i've listened to your story and
i've read your book
twice um and one thing that i'm not sure
you go into is
is how uh your social relationships
suffered when you became sober um that's
a challenge i've had ever since i became
sober and i'm still wrestling with it
now
i'll often go often find myself not
invited
to gatherings with with really close
friends
um some of my friends see me suitable
maybe for a country walk
but not a bachelor party or
any other gathering really and you know
it can be
quite hurtful um it does knock me back a
bit
and you know i see it time and time
again i get
judged as a non-drinker and not included
and i'm just wondering
redshift you've had any experience in
your story
of that and how have you dealt with it
thanks both for
a wonderful show um take care
bye thanks john uh it's a great question
i definitely have had similar
experiences although i think there is a
little bit of a difference
with you being from london because
culturally
uh it's distinct in that um you know
london tends to be a very drinking
centric culture
in general so i suspect that the
challenges might be a little bit more
intense where you live than
where i live the first thing i would say
is that
that disinclusion the idea that you have
these you know quote unquote really
close friends
first of all i would i would wonder how
how close are they really if they're
disinviting you or not inviting you to
do fun stuff
are they really your close friends maybe
they are and maybe they feel like
they're sparing you from putting you in
an uncomfortable situation but either
way
that lack of invitation or or just
inclusion says more about them than it
does about you
and often and i've experienced this um
it's worth considering that you act as a
mirror
to their own behavior so if you're sober
and you're at a bachelor party
and you've got these friends and they're
letting loose and they're going crazy
you being sober in their orbit is a is
is perhaps um an indication that
they might have a problem that they
don't want to look at
so when they see you they're reminded of
their relationship with alcohol
and the extent to which it might be
unhealthy for them so that's one thing
to consider and it helps
with you know empathizing from where
they're coming from i think on some
level
in my own personal case i just made a
ton of new friends
like i needed to uh develop a brand new
community of people who were living
more in alignment with this new value
system that i was developing
and so i would encourage you to do just
that it sounds like you've been sober
for a while but that
you know you you feel cut off or lonely
from your friends so
perhaps try to find a way to tap into a
different community whether it's through
12-step
or even andy ramage's one year no beer
community which is london-centric i
would encourage you to reach out to andy
or to figure out how you can participate
in that movement
because that is just packed with people
who
are experiencing life alcohol free
and then to find new activities and new
things to do i mean personally for me
when i got sober initially i didn't want
to go to a bachelor party because
that was scary and i thought i might
drink today
i have no interest in going to a
bachelor party because
it's just not something you know like
that kind of behavior and activity is
just not something i want to be around
they're very douchey these bachelor
parties yeah hi i'm a douche meter i
don't go to bars
not because i'm scared if i go to a bar
i'm gonna drink but going to a bar when
you're sober just isn't that fun
and what you learn over time and i
suspect you already know this is that
what is meaningful is having meaningful
interactions with those friends that you
care about and when there's a lot of
booze around
those interactions are very surface
level at best and not meaningful
so maybe um shoulder the responsibility
of inviting your friends to do things
with you that interest you that don't
involve alcohol rather than waiting for
them to invite you to do
other stuff or developing a resentment
around not being invited
to do something and doing an inventory
around that resentment
i think would be super helpful uh you
know work
work a program around these uh
emotions that you're having around the
relationships with these friends
i like it i think you know having uh
spent
quite a lot of time in london and seeing
how alcohol is really
like ingrained in the culture there i
think there's an element
like we talked about goggins earlier of
the only you're kind of
it's a little different than being sober
here in southern california
you do feel like when he goes to bed at
10. yeah yeah they're like for their
mountain bike rides
exactly like you're you really are kind
of the only and goggins has embraced
that
being the only he talked about being in
this in in his book
talks about being in the seals um and
the seals
are like train hard and then party hard
and like when they were based in
thailand and he would go to
he didn't want to go to party he wanted
to study and then get up and and
beat their ass and whatever training
they were doing the next day and it
rubbed some people wrong and he was
disinvited or was suspect and it
impacted his
he suspects impacted his which he writes
about and impacted his um
his you know advancement to some of the
teams so
uh you know but he embraced being the
only and that's what he had to do
uh for his own uh kind of well-being but
also it's how he kind of
excelled he embraced it right but he's a
very unique individual
and and you know he had to accept some
level of loneliness that he's
comfortable with
and what i'm gathering from john is that
he doesn't want to
he wants to be connected to his friends
you know this is different this is
qualitatively different in that regard
i just think there's a way to do it that
can be accomplished without the kind of
stigma of
alcohol kind of hovering over the
dynamic itself
no question so if these friends are
really good friends of yours
they're going to be more than happy to
connect with you in a meaningful way
in an environment that doesn't involve
alcohol whether that's a dinner party at
your house
or some athletic activity or some other
thing that you can
mutually enjoy with this person and if
they're not
interested in that then i think it's you
know
worth considering just how good a friend
this person really is
yeah again it all goes back to working
your inventory around this why are you
resentful
what is your part in this how are you
contributing to this and how can you
change the dynamic with certain things
that you can do
in terms of your perspective of these
friends and the activities that you can
or the actions that you can undertake
to you know mend what appears to be
you know fractures in these
relationships
yeah and like any tough thing could end
up being a benefit to you
however it plays out you know going
through the hard thing can become
what helps you become
uh get you to even better place and also
why don't you call them up
and tell them how you feel yeah and have
that conversation
because maybe they're not even aware of
how this is impacting you
and if they are good friends they'll be
able to hear that beautiful
all right one more let's move on thank
you john thanks john go to colorado
hi adam and rich my name is greg
johnston
i'm from colorado i've already adopted a
plant-based
nutrition plan i eat all plants all the
time
as much whole food as i can i'm losing a
ton of weight
got my blood work back everything's good
my blood pressure is down in the great
numbers not on any meds just take my b12
supplement
my question is i'm 52
i've read you know finding ultra um
i've become a great fan of the ritual
podcast
i watched uh you know the world's
toughest race
with you know bear grylls and i live in
colorado
this is the perfect place to start doing
some adventure sports some endurance
sports
what do you see as the way to break into
this for somebody who's 50 plus
you know former college athlete but
really let himself get out of shape
and is now getting back into shape i
would just love to hear some ideas of
how you would take it if you were there
thank you greg great question
the first thing i would say is i can't
shake this sense that you're
waiting for somebody to give you
permission to do this thing
and the truth is you don't need
permission you already have everything
that you require in order to go outside
and begin this process of moving towards
this goal or this dream you have of
doing
adventure sports or endurance sports so
maybe look at what's behind that like
why do you feel like
you can't start until somebody says it's
okay or provides a road map
for you to do so the truth is it's in
the doing that the path is revealed so
you have to just begin so whatever pair
of shoes you happen to have in your
closet
pull those out go outside and
go for a jog and if you can't jog start
with a walk
and then show up the next day and try to
walk a little bit longer
and one day you'll find yourself jogging
a little bit and just
slowly over time expand that
and if you're patient and you're
consistent
i think the answers that you seek will
start to unfurl
before you you don't have to have this
whole plan
completely conceptualized before you
start and
in truth that's the wrong way to think
about it and to go about it to begin
with
i think it's great to set a goal for
yourself if you're like i want to one
day do this crazy race so
i'm going to start with a 10k or
whatever it is to put something on the
calendar that holds you accountable
maybe you can find a friend to do this
with so you have an accountability
partner
to make sure that you get up out of bed
in the morning and get after it but
ultimately this is about falling in love
with a lifestyle shift
that's going to lead you over time into
a a very different place
what that looks like for you is going to
be different than what it might look
like for me or for adam or for somebody
else but find something that you really
enjoy
fall in love with the process and the
lifestyle and everything else
ends up taking care of itself whether
it's gear whether it's which race to do
whether it's you know what gps watch to
buy or what race to sign up for
all of those questions get answered but
if you're stuck in the starting gate
trying to figure it out in your head
you're never going to get to first base
yeah just go for a run
just go for that that's it a hike this
is yeah not
rocket science no just hit the trails
and there is no
secret well i like the idea of being in
colorado you can just like look where
where's the beautiful place you haven't
walked yet or run yet and go check it
out
mm-hmm yeah turn it into a fun adventure
exactly
congratulations on a lifestyle change
yeah those are some really
important big markers i think the other
thing that might be worth commenting on
is it's interesting that you open the
question saying you're 52.
and from that i infer that there's some
sense that maybe
the ship has sailed or it's too late or
you're too old to do that and let me
just abuse you of that notion as
somebody who's turning
54 in a week 52 is not a barrier to this
in fact i'm jealous of you
being at the beginning of what
could quite possibly be the most
enriching
experience of your life if you lean into
it so
get out of your comfort zone put the
fear aside
put one foot in front of the other and
start with tiny steps
make it about the atomic habits that you
build that you build
over time that way it's not daunting you
know you're you're you're eating little
bites
every single day and with that you build
momentum
and these things then develop their own
momentum and they be
they they they become a lot you it it
has a life of its own that will
you know put wind in your sails and and
guide you where you're supposed to go
absolutely and i do understand though
being in colorado seeing those
incredible i mean i get i get it like if
if being 52
seems like a problem when you're in
colorado surrounded by endurance
athletes that are just
that's whizzing by yeah that's true yeah
because everybody's crazy fit
yeah yeah yeah yeah they all look like
they're you know lining up for the kona
world championships like every single
day at the coffee shop
exactly i i get it i get it forget about
that
yeah it has nothing to do with that no
this is about
your relationship with yourself and the
person that you want to become
boom all right that's some good [ __ ]
right there
drop in wisdom how do you feel me yeah i
feel great i feel like this is a good
place to vent
my concerns for the well-being of
humanity
and uh in a safe space i'm glad to
provide that
venue for you so you can go home i can
go home be the best
husband and dad and swim run aficionado
that you can
you know what i appreciate that about
you right on right on right on
just getting in the mcconnell you got to
get it tomorrow i can't wait to hear
about it
cool uh we'll be back in two weeks in
the meantime
follow adam at adam skolnik on all the
socials if you'd like your message
considered leave us a voicemail at
four six two 424-235-4626 you can find
me at rich roll pretty much
everywhere please take a moment to hit
that subscribe button on youtube
apple or spotify check the show notes on
the episode page at richroll.com we'll
put links up to everything that we
discussed today as always
and that's it i think we did it today
appreciate you guys thanks for the love
see you back here in a couple days with
another amazing episode
tbd who knows what it's going to be who
knows
who knows what the world is going to
look like we'll still be here
in a couple days it'll still be well
that's the funny thing with this show we
always think we're going to talk about
something and then the world
spins off its access and it seems no
longer relevant
it's gonna it's you know what it's gonna
cycle back to normal
it is going to at some stage all right
nostradamus
we're gonna get there all right together
peace plants
[Music]
namaste
you